LEAFS ARE 5 FOR 9  IN THE
MITCHELL MARNER SNAPS AT HOME!
1-0, TORONTO.G TAKES A HIT FROM
MATTHEWS.E GAME.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT A FEW TIMES.
ONLY SHOT ON GOAL FOR EITHER
TEAM WAS S
>> HE MADE HIMSELF LOOK REAL
BIG AND THAT'S WHAT THE
PANTHERS ARE LOTO JUMP BACK INT
LINEUP.
>> PANTHERSRS PANTHERS GET
THEIR FIRSMBERG FIRES WIDE.APPR
GOY NETTER IN TORONTO.
THEY HAVE A BOATLOAD OF SHOTS
ON GOAL.
BOBROVSKYTO THE OFFENSIVE ZONE.
PUCK AT THE NET. TORONTO WIN A
CUP?
>> I THINK SO.
I DON'T THINK ATTENDING IS
HE IS A CENTERPIECE OUT THERE.
CONSECUTUT
>> EVEN THOUGH THE PANTHERS PAS
SHIFT.
LOOKING TO HOLD IT IN THE ZONE.
AND HE DOES.
MARCHMAN GETS TO THE NET. HE IS
WORK OFTO THE PANTHER
LOGO AT CENTER.
OR SKI MINUTES GONE, THIRD
MATTHEWS DRIVING TO THE NET.
KNEE LENDER CONTROLS.
>> THE TORONTE WAY THROUGH.
>> GOALSCORING CHANCES HERE IN
THIS THIRD PERIOD.
HERE IS  FLORIDA IS AN
FOR IT.
THE PANTHERS WILL GET THE
TRYING TO GO THE OTHER WAY WITH
NUMBERS!